bonjour et bienvenue dans ce 78 weekend
du premier vendredi de janvier je vous
permet tout d'abord je permet tout
d'abord de vous présenter tous mes
meilleurs vœux pour cette nouvelle année
qui commence des vœux bien sûr de
bonheur de santé ou encore de réussite
allez retour sur ce qui a fait
l'actualité de cette fin d'année des
invités pour m'accompagner pendant cette
demi-heure tout d'abord Jean-René Martin
bonjour vous viendrez nous parler dans
quelques instants d'un concours de tir
lart qui a lieu à hencour et puis je
recevrai également deux chanteuses Naël
et Laura pour la sortie d'un duo mais
d'abord direction guillancour le centre
de loisirs en inclusion collective fun
pour tous a reçu ce jeudi le grand chef
canois Arnaud tabarek Parin de
l'association l'association qui est
toujours en proie à des difficultés
financières Anthony
R en fonction de son handicap chaque
enfant épluge découpe les fruits ou
presse les oranges au menu ce midi une
raclette et une salabe de fruits pour le
moins exotique en dessert confectionné
au côté d'un grand chef on a fait plein
de fruits différents alors il y avait
des mangues il y avait des fruits du
Dragon il y avait aussi des pommes des
bananes quelque chose qui qui leur qui
leur parle et puis à côté de ça on leur
fait découvrir des nouvelles saveurs des
nouvelles textures des nouveaux goûts
des nouvelles odeurs et et on sent
qu'ils sont super effceptifs quoi ils
sont ils sont très curieux en fait lors
de notre première venue il y a un mois
du fun pour tous devait faire face à un
manque de 50000 € réduction des
effectifs et du temps de travail oblige
les employés sont toujours au chômage
partiel mais l'accueil des enfants ne
s'arrête pas pour autant un dossier a
été donc déposé à l'agence régionale de
santé une rencontre est prévue avec le
Conseil Général et le préfet a été saisi
du dossier de quoi être optimiste pour
la nouvelle année mais ce centre de
loisir en inclusion collective n'est pas
encore sauvé avec la direction
départementale du travail on a on a
arrêté une date donc à fin février pour
le chômage partiel donc on devrait
reprendre une activité normale début
mars après je peux pas vous dire ça va
dépendre de la situation financière si
la situation financière reste comme elle
est on redemandera une autre période de
chômage partiel si ça s'améliore et ben
je pense qu'on pourra reprendre une
activité normal en 2012 du fun pour tous
a accueilli 84 enfants souffrant de
déficience mental issu de 25 communes
des
iveline il reste encore quelques jours
de vacances pour les scolaires et
pourtant vous allez le voir certains en
on profit ont profité de leur congé de
Noël pour réviser des lycéens assidus
qui suivent les cours de soutien
proposés par l'association Archimède à
voisin le
bretonneu ils profitent de leur congé
pour réviser comme à chaque vacance
scolaire l'association Archimède propose
des cours de soutien cela se passe à
voisin le Bretonneux ce jeudi matin
leçon de mathématiquees en petit groupe
Antoine lycéen est assidu à ses cours
depuis 2 ans au début c'était mes
parents la première fois il y a 2 ans et
puis du coup c'est moi qui un peu
sollicite un peu mes parents quand je me
sens pas en difficulté on est moins
nombreux il y a un prof un prof pour si
élèves donc c'est beaucoup plus facile
ils sont forcément plus attentifs et
puis d'une part parce qu'ils sont moins
nombreux et surtout parce que là ils
sont plus demandeurs demandeur pour
recommencer les exercices du premier
trimestre mais également revoir les
bases d'apprentissage et les méthodes de
travail ce qui manque souvent le plus
pour acquérir une bonne autonomie cette
situation en tout petit groupe ça permet
à l'enseignant de travailler vraiment
individuell avec chacun et une fois
qu'on a expliqué qu'on a donné bien sûr
quelque chose à faire parce que ça passe
beaucoup par l'application des méthodes
et applications tout de suite sur des
sujets des exercices et bien ça permet
après l'élève il est tout seul avec son
problème et c'est bah c'est très
bénéfique he bien que ça puisse un peu
les stressés ils sont dans une situation
ils ne sont pas notés donc là c'est
acquérir aussi de l'autonomie à l'issue
de ce stage un bilan sera donné aux
familles dans la moitié des cas les
professeurs d'Archimède conseillent de
poursuivre ses cours de soutien cours
qui sont aussi organisés de façon
hebdomadaire pendant toute l'année il
faut compter 16 € pour une heure de
soutien pour un collégien et jusqu'à 18
€ de l'heure pour un
lycéen et on va quitter le soutien
scolaire pour se rendre à hencour pour
un concours annuel tir àarc Jean-René
Martin bonjour vous êtes vice-président
de la compagnie d'arc d'éancour il y A
380 archers qui sont attendus au
complexe de l'Europe ce ce weekend c'est
un concours qui est sélectif pour le
Championnat du Monde qui aura lieu fin
janvier à nî autant dire qu'il y aura du
beau monde rembl ce weekend oui alors il
va y avoir du beau monde effectivement
il est sélectif pour le Championnat du
Monde disons qu'il est d'abord sélectif
pour le championnat de France je faisais
monter la oui oui vous avez raison vous
avez raison mais mais on l'a un peu
découvert sur le tar en plus si vous
voulez c'était des dates réservées ce
weekend là et un un weekend du mois de
de décembre qui était dédié au à la
sélection pour les meilleures archés au
championnat du monde donc ben tant mieux
pour nous parce que ça fait ça fait
venir du monde et donc donc je 380
archés alors il y a la fois les les
archers j'ai envie de dire du dimanche
de ceux qui pratiquent en loisir et puis
il y aura aussi quand même des des
sportifs à guérri alors pour une bonne
partie c'est des sportifs acéris il y en
a beaucoup qui sont des sportifs il y en
a certains qui viendront pardon qui sont
des sportifs de haut niveau et puis
effectivement il y a ceux qui font la
compétition mais de la compétition
loisir c'estàd qu'il font ça tous les
dimanches qui écument les concours de
des Yvelines tous les dimanches avec
leur le plus grand plaisir bon il se
trouve que notre concours est un peu
plus gros que les autres par la date par
la proximité des championnat donc en
fait on a la chance de
pouvoir accueillir beaucoup de monde
ouis justement 380 arché c'est c'est
important pour ce premier weekend de de
janvier euh comment vous faites pour
attirer autant de monde alors c'est quoi
le le secret alors euh le secret le
secret disons qu'il y a il y a le ce que
je vous ai dit à l'heure la date qui est
proche des championnats les premiers
championnats seront à la fin de à la fin
du mois il y a ensuite le fait que il y
a une il y a eu une trêve des confiseurs
et ils ont peut-être besoin de se
dépenser un peu de venir de venir
reprendre goût au tir pour beaucoup ils
ont pas plus s'entraîner pendant les
vacances parce que les gymnases étaient
fermés donc en plus ça fait l'occasion
de de venir tirer et puis on a une salle
au complexe de l'Europe qui offre des
conditions de tir qui sont bien
agréables on a de la place on aune bonne
luminosité on peut mettre le maximum de
cible et puis notre expérience fait que
on arrive à faire un concours qui est
qui est agréable et les gens aiment
revenir alors je l'ai d un concours
sélectif pour les championnats de France
mais aussi pour les championnats du
monde ça veut dire qu'il y aura
forcément des pointures il y aura
notamment Sophie daudemont qui a été
médaillé olympique à Pékin marque
classique voilà voilà Sophie Domont
Sophie dodmont était si vous vous
souvenez de Pékin ça été la première
médaille olympique française qui a
débloqué le compteur tout le monde
attendait on pleurait parce qu'on avait
pas de médaille donc elle était en
c'était en équipe avec ses deux
collègues en en AR classique l'année
dernière Sophie donemont a changé d'arme
elle est passée en AR capouli avec tout
autant de bonheur puisque elle avait
quitté l'équipe de France en art
classique elle est rentrée en équipe de
France là je vous a pas demandé ce
concours annuel c'est 2 x 18 m en arc
classique arc à pouli c'est tout arme
confondu c'est-à-dire qu'en fait c'est
arc classique arc à pouli la cible
change mais là là en l'occurrence Sophie
viendra en arcapouli et Sophie a a été
championne du pardon elle était 3e au
championnat du monde juste avant avant
le le l'hiver là et elle a elle a
également battu le record de France en
salle il y a 15 il y a 3 semaines juste
avant les vacances de de Noël donc on
espère qu'elle recommence alors si on
veut voir tirer Sophie Domont il faut
venir à quelle heure sopie sophie donmon
va tirer samedi euh pardon dimanche
matin à 9h et mais elle restera pour les
pour les pour les matchs pour faire les
alors ce qu'on les matchs c'est quoi je
me permets euh on on innove un peu enfin
on l'a fait l'année dernière Guy en cour
le fait aussi depuis depuis de
nombreuses années c'estàd qu'en fait le
les archers font un tir qualificatif
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait ils font un tir
face à une cible pour marquer un maximum
de points donc 20 20 volet de trois
flèches ça leur fait 600 points à faire
plus ils se rapproche des 600 points
meilleurs ils sont c'est ils sont sur le
sur le 10 bah pour vous situer Sophie
Sophie donmont en arcapouli a battu le
record de France juste avant les
vacances avec 589 donc si vous voyez
elle a perdu 11 points dans la bagarre
et c'est à peu près tout et euh vous
donc on fait un classement à partir de
ces ces tirs qualificatifs on garde les
16 meilleur dans chacune des armes et
ils font des matchs
euh deux par deux c'est et ça les matchs
c'est être à découvrir plutôt dimanche à
partir de 16h voilà les matchs sera à
l'issue de de des différents tires
qualificatifs puisque les 380 archés
doivent tirer on fera les matchs à ce
moment-là donc pour ceux qui sont
intéressés samedi et dimanche jusqu'à
16h sont les qualifications les tirs
qualificatifs et dimanche à partir de
16h ce sont les duels tout à fait c'est
ça c'est peut-être la partie la plus ah
bah c'est plus c'est plus télégénique
quand c'est ce qu'on présente en général
au JO c'est ce qu'on présente en par que
c'est guerre que j qu'on voit du tu
tirarc à la télé donc merci à vous et
donc en fait le le c'est essentiellement
cette partie là parce que là vous vous
suivez il y a le suspense puisque il y a
ça se passe en en 7 il tire que ça dure
une petite demi-heure un match et deux
volets de tris pardon trois volets de de
de trois flèches et puis après s'il y a
égalité on donc l'entrée libre au
complexe Europe à en cours si on veut
assister à ça al on sait peut-être pas
on le sait peut-être pas trop mais dans
les iin est le département qui compte le
plus de licenciés en tir à l'arc en
France tout à fait c'est étonnant tout à
fait euh oui on est peut-être cassé dans
les mêm genrees de sport que l'quitation
ou le ou le golf qui où les ielines sont
aussi largement en tête on a l'ORD je
pas les chiffres exact mais 2500 à 2700
licenciés dans le département alors
c'est sûr que vis-àis d'autres sports ça
paraît très peu mais en fait au niveau
du tir àarc c'est énorme je je donnais
comme
comparaison un département comme sans
sans préjugés comme le les pirén
orientale parce que je connais le le
chiffre et un taux de licencier qui est
de l'ordre de 400 à 450 donc pratiement
2500 pour les en plus il y a 6
compagnies d'Arc à 50 ans en Ibel il y a
une compagnie d'arc par ville sauf sauf
à La Verrière la compagnie d'arc B
encour existe depuis avir 97 vous y êtes
dedans tombé dedans dès le mois de
septembre 97 mais qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui vous a plu dans le dans le
tir àarc alors c'est la maîtrise
technique c'est la difficulté comme
beaucoup de gens en fait j'en ai fait en
village de vacances et j'ai eu envie de
continuer
en en retournant chez moi à une rentrée
et bon il y avait pas de club où j'étais
le jour où je suis arrivé à encour le
club était tout près de chez moi donc
j'ai qu'est-ce qui vous a PL alors bien
au début c'était un sport je dirais un
peu comme un autre ben plus vous voyez
peut-être mon physique donc je suis pas
un physique de grand sportif donc ça
peut permettre quel que soit le gabarit
c'est moi qui dit je suis d'accord non
mais GL globalement en fait ça nous
permet de de de bah de mine de rien de
nous dépenser mentalement et un petit
peu physiquement aussi quand même mine
de rien et et puis ben la précision
l'adresse le l'envie de faire un peu de
compétition et et de participer
éventuellement aussi à des championnats
de France puis ça m arrivé aussi merci
en tout cas jeanon Martin d'être venu
sur le plate de cette suite weekend et
je rappelle raelle donc ce concours
annuel de tir àar qui a lieu samedi et
dimanche au complex Europe en court avec
des matchs à partir de 16h ce dimanche
merci beaucoup à vous allez un tout
autre sujet pour continuer ce 78 weekend
la belle initiative du Secours populaire
des iveline qui a convié des personnes
âgées et isolées à participer à une
balade en bateau mouche c'était à
l'occasion du Nouvel An Olivier Manis
calco et Lodi moine ont embarqué avec
eux une croisière sur la scène pour
voguer hors du quotidien 31 décembre une
cinquantaine de personnes âgées isolées
étai invité par le Secours populaire des
ivelines pour un déjeuner convivial en
bateauouche un bon repas une chanteuse
de cabaret qui reprend les grands air
français le tout entouré des plus beaux
monuments parisiens tout été réuni pour
sortir ses seiors d'un quotidien morose
parfois empli de
solitude un rêve depuis X années j'ai
pas pris de temps comme ça j'ai perdu
mon mari il y a pas longtemps donc
passons et vraiment une une journ une
journée inoubliable un repas on ne peut
rien dire c'est super génial une
ambiance des amis des voisins rien à
dire trop belle journée à vraiment à
garder en rêve et en fond de la tête on
a aussi une pensée pour les personnes
âgées qui ont des conditions de vie
difficile mais en plus qui souffre
beaucoup de l'isolement et de le une
croisière de riches pour les pauvres
pour nous c'est vraiment il faut
remercier les amis desines c'est une
très très bonne initiative nous avons
beaucoup de personnes seules
et le problème c'est qu'elles osent pas
le dire donc elles ont un peu honte de
leur situation et on arrive pas à à les
regrouper tous pour
pouvoir qui profite d'une journée telle
que telle que celle-ci pour avoir à
encour nous avons plus de 200 familles
dans le besoin et nous n'avons pu avoir
que que 7 personnes qui ont voulu venir
le repas se tenait cette fois le midi
mais à l'avenir le Secours populaire
souhaiterit accompagner ces personnes
isolées lors du réveillon de la nouvelle
année en France près de 5 millions de
personnes sont aujourd'hui seules soit
11% de la population parmi les seiors le
chiffre est plus alarmant encore avec
une personne isolée sur 5 chez les plus
de 75
ans une galerie photo actu c'est ce que
proposent de jeunes entrepreneurs cela
se passe à véis 2 et cler Cambier et
elodim moine les ont
rencontrés dans la galerie marchande de
véis 2 ce magasin éphémère propose des
photographies d'art un espace assez
réduit mais l'ensemble de la collection
visible via ces tablettes un nouveau
concept de vente 2.0 vous avez accès en
fait à une visualisation de chacun des
formats et de chacune desfinition grâce
à l'application par exemple si vous
souhaitez un petit format classique
missar Louise et cadre vous pouvez le
voir ici et bien sûr voir le rendu que
cela donnera chez vous la galerie
virtuelle propose 10000 photographie du
monde entier un jury d'experts les
sélectionne avec les deux fondateurs
Paul Henry et Romain leur édition est
limitée de 50 à 500 exemplaires pour des
prix osillants entre 29 et 450 €. la
société a été lancée en octobre 2012
alors que ces jeunes entrepreneurs
étaient encore étudiants on rent tous
les de d'échang à l'étranger on était
étudiant euh moi j'avais passé beaucoup
de temps à shanghï et en arrivant à
reins la ville dans laquelle on a étudié
je souhaitais découvrir mon appartement
d'une d'une photoune belle photo de la
skyline shanghayenne et j'ai rien trouvé
sur internet ni dans les magasins de
déco et je me suis rendu compte de deux
choses que j'étais loin d'être le seul à
chercher les photographies de lieux
particuliers qui avaient du sens pour
moi photos d'art pour découvrir mon
intérieur et euh l'autre chose c'est
qu'il y avait énormément de photographes
de talent prêt à à exposer et à vendre
des photographies de grande qualité de
toutes ces grandes villes sans
expérience professionnelle romain et
Paul Henri se sont fait épauler par des
accélérateurs d'entreprise leurs coach
les ont aidé à lever 230000 € de fond le
mois dernier prochaine étape être
présent physiquement dans les grandes
villes de France il reste d'ici là
accessible en ligne et jusque fin mai à
véis allez on va quitter le monde de la
photo on va maintenant passer au monde
de la musique avec deux chanteuses en
plateau avec moi Laura et Naël Naël
bonjour Vous habitez au montig et Laur
vous habitez noisi- le grand dans la vie
vous êtes amis et vous avez décidé de
vous associer toutes les deux pour faire
un premier duo qui s'appelle te rendre
fou alors d'abord qui a eu l'idée de ce
duo bah c'est un petit peu toutes les
deux en fait justement comme on est amis
dans la vie et qu'on chantait chacune de
notre côté on s'est dit pourquoi pas
faire quelque chose ensemble
retranscrire cette complicité là dans
dans un duo et ça s'est fait tout
naturellement en fait a mais il faut
avoir le même des voix qui s'accordent
non quand on décide de faire un duo ou
alors c'est c'est plus simple que ça
vrai nous de base on n pas forcément des
voix similaires mais justement on avait
envie de jouer sur ce contraste là et
voir ce que ça allait donner bah pour
leudo et ça l' ça l'a vraiment bien fait
doncouis c'est vrai que c'est avant tout
une histoire d'amitié on avait un peu
envie de de se faire plaisir en faisant
ce titre ensemble on y a pris beaucoup
de plaisir on se connaît beaucoup enfin
ça fait un petit moment qu'on se connaît
on a déjà travaillé sur d'autres projets
donc voilà là on avait envie de se
lancer c'est vrai qu'on a pas du tout le
le même timbre de voix ni la même façon
de chanter mais sur ce même style
musical au départ oui un peu je pense
oui aprè on a des influences un peu
différentes mais sinon on est dans le
même style et comment vous avez
travaillé notamment l'écriture la
musique qui a comment s'est passé la
composition le choix de la musique et
pour la composition en fait on est allit
la chercher directement auprès d'un ami
qu'on qu'on connaît tout les deux aussi
donc voilà c'est quand être d'accord sur
VO on est parti directement voir voir
cette personne don c'est VR6 et euh en
fait voilà ça s'est fait ensemble on a
vraiment fait ça très rapidement mais
entre nous on a pris enfin voilà on
s'est un peu écouté et on a fait le truc
ensemble on l'a pas on l'a pas fait
chacun de son côté tout ça on a
construit le morceau ensemble et pour
l'écriture c'est pareil en fait l'or et
moi on était à la maison on a on a
décidé de se lancer un petit peu sur on
a passé la nuit sur le son et puis voilà
on a trouvé les mélodies et puis on a
écrit ensemble parce que on trouvait ça
important justement de de mettre de nos
deux talents en fait pour le titre c'est
c'est pas simple d'écrire ensemble non
non non c'est pas toujours vous écouté
ça l'air facile on se met autour d'une
table en fait comme on avait un peu le
thème on avait petite idée en tête on
était parti un peu sur bah enfin sur Al
le thème c'est c'est la reconquête
exactement ça exement donc on était
parti sur la même idée et en fait ça
s'est fait vraiment on s'est pas trop
pris la tête en fait on avait un peu la
même idée on a suivi le truc c'est vrai
que pour le coup ça ça ça a pas été très
difficile en fait justement d'écrire ce
titre ensemble on a pas trop eu de de
mal à à se mettre d'accord donc ça a été
mais c'est vrai que ça peut être
difficile
de avec un are arti ouais c'est pas
évident et pour et pour le partage des
vois comment ça s'est passé après on
écoutter un extrait parce que du coup
bah en fait quand on a écouté la
finalité du son on s'est dit bon bah moi
je fais cette phrase là toi celle-ci
parce qu'on a pas voulu faire justement
un couplet chacune ou quoi on a vraiment
voulu mêler nos voix au maximum en
alternant souvent nos voix et c'est vrai
qu'en fait sur le texte on a dit bon ça
c'est toi ça c'est vraiment de l'échange
quoi pour que même sur scène ou autre il
puisse vraiment y avoir un vrai échange
que soit pas que l'une et puis l'autre
qui attend pendant ce temps-là donc du
coup voilà on a vraiment échangé sur ce
sur ce titre là on s'est réparti en
fonction de ce qu'on avait envie de
chanter on s'est pas trop voilà on s'est
pas marché dessus du tout bon alors
voilà pour les pour les explications
théoriques maintenant on va pas si j'ai
pas envie fa la pratique mais presque on
va quand même écouter un extrait de te
rendre fou pour que les téléspectateurs
se rendent compte de ce travail en
duo
Pr
tu es à moi c'est
tout ne résiste
pas
touter je n'ai pas besoin de
te
dire je t'aime et tu peux le
ressentir mon corps fais s
men je connais ça ne d pas tu es le
CH je
prend voà on comprend bien le mélange
des des des voix mais qui est un mélange
très harmonieux hein vous dites vous
n'avez pas la même tessiture de voix
mais finalement ça justement ça sent pas
énormément dans le titre on a fait
exprès on a bien accordé je pense qu'en
fait la complicité elle est passée aussi
au travers de de la musique quoi
donc votre style musical on a
l'impression qu'il y a un peu de de Zook
c'est pas complètement Zook mais c'est
un peu une B ècoup d'A infuences voilà
après on a nos influences personnelles
justement quelles sont-elles vos
influences personnelles bah moi de base
c'est vrai que j'ai plus grandi avec la
soul le R&B enfin toutes ces musiques là
après j'ai découvert le Zook et puis
voilà j'ai essayé de mixer un peu toutes
ces influences voilà moi pareil c'est
Hipop RnB beaucoup de Zook pas mal
d'influence aussi par rapport à mes
racines tout ce qui était des îles quoi
et puis voilà moi le Z j'aime vous dit
vous RAC vous êtes je suis de l'île de
la Réunion voilà donc tout ce qui est
musique tropicale et cetera aussi de la
réun oui j'ai des nouvelles de mes
parents tout se passe bien c'est vrai
qu'ils ont eu une coupure d'électricité
donc donc voilà mais pour l'instant ça
s'est calmé apparemment donc ça va
rentrer dans l'ordre voà une petite
aparté vous éez de la Réunion profite
pour
poser d'ailles je les salue voilà un
petit salut très à la Réunion
effectivement ce premier titre est
disponible depuis le 17 décembre on peut
l'entendre où sur tous les sites de
téléchargement
Lego t les plateformes de téléchargement
légal et puis et puis voilà après en
radio ça va rentrer petit à petit
normalement sur Tropic FM et quelques
autres radios peut-être local au niveau
des c'est compliqué de se faire
connaître oui ouais c'est vrai même avec
tous les sites justement de
téléchargement qui existent on dit c'est
plus facileou c'est compliqué parce que
faut aussi avoir pas mal de contact en
fait dans le milieu je pense que c'est
aussi ça qui nous aide à avancer et si
on les a pas bah concrètement on peut
rester très longtemps dans l'ombre en
fait après c'est vrai qu'innet facilite
quand même pas mal la communication
qu'on a une petite base fan avec des
gens qui nous suivent depuis un petit
moment donc c'est vrai que ça ça
facilite quand même le fait de de
pouvoir se faire connaître mais après la
médiatisation c'est ça qui est un peu
plus compliqué jeai d c'était votre
premier duo mais vous avez aussi une
carrière chacune un petit mot justement
sur votre actualité ce que vous faites
vous séparément en tant que bah nous on
avait déjà travaillé ensemble donc moi
mon mon titre juste avant le di c'était
love de toi donc c'était une
collaboration oui voilà toujours cétait
une collaboration avec Naël et un
chanteur aussi qui s'appelle Johan et
puis pour l'instant c'est vraiment on se
on se cantonne au titre et euh on va le
défendre à fond et puis après on
reprendra nos carrières solo mais pour
l'instant c'est vraiment le duo euh h
moi pareil en fait voilà j'ai j'avais
travaillé un sur un album avant qui
s'appelait je ne changerai pas et puis
euh donc après on a travaillé un petit
peu ensemble sur ces titre et euh
maintenant bon ben voilà on se concentre
sur le duo on vient de le sortir donc on
a envie de de voir si ça prend on vient
lui donner une petite impulsion et puis
par la suite on verra ensuite en
fonction de ce que les gens demandent de
de de l'accueil que ça vair ça veut dire
qu'il pourrait y en avoir d'autres des
duo comme ça ça vous a plu l'expérience
ah oui ça c'est sûr on l'a fait pourre
plaisir après on va pas pouvoir le faire
tout le temps parce qu'on va pas non
plus lasser les gens et puis je pense
qu'on a aussi envie de travailler avec
avec d'autres personnes aussi mais
toujours ensemble en fait c'est vrai
qu'on travaille souvent ensemble en fait
sur nos projets on se concert tout le
temps un petit peu donc et vous avez une
actualité aussi commune parce que là on
peut écouter effectivement sur la site
de téléchargement mais on peut aussi
vous voir en concert ce sera le premier
février dans un
festival c'est un concert live en fait
voilà avec d'autres artistes et puis
après on va avoir plein de scènes aussi
en janvier donc ça on le mettra sur nos
pages fans et cetera mais c'est vrai
qu'on va pas mal tourner ensemble
justement alors moi j'avais la date du
1er février c'était au blanc Ménil vous
avez des dates sur les Yvelines non ou
non sur les ivelines c'est pas encore
peut-être qu'on fera une petite date au
capenti j'espère donc c'est une
discothèque dans le 78 mais c'est vrai
qu'on a plus de de prestations pour
l'instant en discothèque puisque c'est
une musique pour l'instant qui est assez
porté caribéenne et qui est pas pour
l'instant qui on n pas reçu la
médiatisation pour pouvoir aller plus
loin mais c'est vrai qu'au niveau du
live par contre c'est cette date qui
était intéressante à retenir parce que
là on va vraiment être avec des vrais
musiciens des artistes et c'est ce qui
nous c'est ce qui nous plaît le PLUS
quoi donc le 1er février au cariban live
au blancmil donc un festival avec
plusieurs groupes de musique merci à
vous deux d'être venu
sur juste avant de partir est-ce que
vous avez fait vous avez une bonne
résolution pour 2014 question alors moi
j'en ai jamais des résolutions parce que
les gens les tiennent pas en général
donc je ne préfère pas en avoir et puis
je vis vraient année comme il se doit
puis voilà moi c'est pareil j'en ai pas
j'en ai pas spécialement effectivement
ça va être continuer un peu sur la
lancée continuer à se battre à défendre
un peu nos projets et puis voilà surtout
rester soudé avec la famille les proches
c'est important ouais ça c'est bien vrai
allez on va de notre côté par contre
écouter les 50is pour savoir s'ils ont
des ils ont pardon des résolutions pour
2014 et pour ma part je vous souhaite un
excellent weekend à très
bientôtavoir beaucoup
d'argent la santé évoluer dans mon
travail sage en cour bien mon trer et
puis et puis rentrer rentrer dans
l'école que je souhaite après le bac que
que ça continue que tout aille bien ça
ira très bien comme ça essayer de de
perdre un peu de poids j'en ai pas
spécialement non peut-être faire un peu
plus de sport déjàir une bonne
santé et puis et puis que les
enfants travaillent bien à l'école
arrêtez de fumer
absolument ça ce sera un premier motif
arrêtez de fumer aussi